cold fusion yeah this this idea this
dream uh this interesting physical goals
seemed to be impossible uh but perhaps
it's possible do you think it is
possible do you think down the line
somewhere in in um
in the far distance as possible to
achieve Fusion at a low temperature
it's very very very unlikely
um and this comes from
um so this would require a pretty
fundamental shift in our understanding
of of physics like as we know it now and
we know a heck of a lot about how
nuclear reactions occur
um but by the way what's interesting is
that there's they actually have a
different name for it they call it
leaner like low energy nuclear reactions
but we do have low energy nuclear
reactions we know these it's because
these come from uh particularly the weak
um interaction the weak force uh nuclear
force
and so it's at this point
um
you know as a scientist you always keep
yourself open because but you also
demand proof right and that's the thing
it almost requires a breakdown on the
theoretical physics side so something
some deeper understanding about quantum
mechanics of this so the quantum
tunneling some some weird yeah and and
people have looked at that but even like
something like Quantum tunneling has a
limit as to what it can actually do so
there there are people who are genuine
you know that really want to see it make
it but you know sort of goes to the
extraordinary I mean we know Fusion
happens at these high energies like when
we know this extremely accurately and I
can show you a plot that shows that as
you go to lower lower energy it
basically becomes immeasurable so if
you're going down this other pathway it
means there's really a very
different physical mechanism involved so
all I would say is that I I actually
poke in my head once in a while to see
what's going on and that area
um and as scientists we should always
try to make ourselves open
um and uh but in this one it's like but
show me something that I can measure and
that it's repeatable and then and then
it then it's going to take more
extraordinary effort and to date this is
not met that threshold in my opinion so
I'm even more so than just mentioning or
in that question thinking about people
that are claiming to have achieved cold
fusion I'm more thinking even about
people who are studying black holes and
they're they're basically trying to
understand
the function of you know theoretical
physicists that are doing the Long Haul
yeah trying to investigate like okay
what is happening at the singularity
what is uh this kind of
uh holographic projections on a plate
these weird freaking things that are out
there in the universe and like somehow
accidentally they start to figure out
something weird yeah and then all of a
sudden there's weirdness all over the
place already yeah somehow that
weirdness will yeah I think in a time
scale probably of a hundred years or so
that weirdness will open
uh so it just seems like nuclear fusion
and black holes and all of this are two
they're next door neighbors a little bit
too much for like you'll find something
yeah interesting let me tell you a story
about this yes okay it's a real story oh
yeah
so they're a really really clever
scientists in the in the end of the late
1800s in the world you talk about like
James Clark Maxwell when you talk about
Lord Calvin and you talk about Lorenz
actually who named after these other
ones and yeah on and on and on and like
Faraday and they discovered
electromagnetism holy cow and it's like
they figure out all these things and yet
there were these weird
things going on that you couldn't quite
figure out it's like what the heck is
going on with us right but we teach this
all the time in in physics classes right
so what was going on well there's just a
few
there's just a few kind of things things
unchecked but basically we're at the end
of Discovery because we figured out how
everything works because we've got we've
got basically Newtonian mechanics and
we've got Maxwell's equations which
describe basically how matter gets
pushed around and how electromagnetism
Works holy cow what a feat
there are these few nagging things
like for instance there's certain kinds
of rocks that for some reason like if
you put a photographic plate around it
it like it's burned or it gets an image
on it like well where's the
electromagnetism in that there's no
electromagnetic properties of this rock
oh yeah and the other thing too is that
if I if I take this wonderful classical
derivation of how a a something that is
hot about how it releases radiation
everything looks fantastic perfect match
oh until I get to high frequencies
of the light and then it basically just
the whole thing falls apart in fact it
gives a physical explanation which is
total nonsense it tells you that every
object should basically be producing an
infinite amount of heat and by the way
here's the Sun and we can look at the
Sun and we can figure out it's made out
of hydrogen and Lord Kelvin actually
made a very famous you know calculation
who was basically one of the founders of
thermodynamics so you look at the
hydrogen hydrogen has a certain energy
content that you know the latent heat
basically of hydrogen we know the mass
of the sun because we knew the size of
it and he conclusively proved that
basically there could only the the sun
could only make net energy for about two
or three thousand years
so therefore all this nonsense about
like deep is like because clearly the
sun can only last for two or three
thousand years if you think about the
captain this is basically the chemical
energy content of hydrogen and what
comes along in one decade
basically one guy sitting in a postal
office you know in Switzerland figures
out that all these you know Einstein of
course which was like figured out all
this create like took these these
seemingly unconnected things and it's
like boom there it is this is what it
was in just him but it was like there's
quantum physics like this explains this
other disaster and then this other guy
my hero
Ernest Rutherford experimentalist
did the most extraordinary experiment
which is like which was that okay they
had these funny rocks they emitted these
particles in fact they called them alpha
particles Alpha just a in the alphabet
right because it was the first thing
that they discovered
and what were they doing so they were
they were taking these alpha particles
and I by the way I do this to all my
students because it's a demonstration of
what you should be as a good scientist
so he took these Alpha things and he was
classically trained physicists knew
everything about momentum scattering and
so forth like that and he took this and
these Alpha which clearly were some kind
of energy but they couldn't quite figure
out what it was so so let's try to
figure that we'll actually use this to
try to probe the nature of matter so he
took this
to these alpha particles and a very very
thin gold foil and so what you wanted to
see was that as they were going through
the way that they would scatter based on
classical in fact a coulomb collision
based on classical mechanics this will
tell me reveal something about what the
nature of the charge distribution is in
matter because they didn't know like
where the hell is this stuff coming from
even though they'd solved that
electromagnetism they didn't know like
what made up charges okay very
interesting on through it goes
and so what did you set up so it turns
out in the in these experiments what you
did was because if these out these
so-called Alphas which actually now we
know is something else as they go
through they would deflect how much they
deflect tells you how strong an electric
field they saw so you put detectors
because if you put if you put like a
piece of glass in front of this what
will happen is that when the alpha
particle hits it literally gives a
little a little bit of light like this
it scintillates a little blue flash so
he would train his students or post like
whatever the heck they were at the time
you have to train yourself because you
have to put yourself in the dark for
like hours to get your eyes adjusted and
then they would start the experiment and
they would sit there and literally count
the things and they could see this
pattern developing which was revealing
about what was going on but there was
also another part to the experiment
which was that
it's like here's the alphas here's the
source they're going this way they could
tell they were going in One Direction
only basically they're going in this
direction
and you put all these over here because
you want to see how they deflect and
bend through it but you put a control in
the experiment but you basically put
glass particle glass glass plates back
here because obviously everything should
just deflect but nothing should bounce
back so it's a controlling experiment
but what did they see
they saw things bouncing back
like what the hell
like that fit no model of any idea right
but Rutherford like refused to like
ignore what was a clear like they
validated it and he sat down and based
on classical physics he made the most
extraordinary discovery which was the
nucleus
which is a very very strange Discovery
what what I mean by that because what he
could figure out from this is that in
order for these particles to bounce back
and hit this plate they were hitting
something that must be heavier than them
and that that basically something like
99.999 of the mass of the matter that
was in this gold foil was in something
that contained about one trillionth of
the volume of it
and that's called the nucleus
and until and you talk about so how
revealing is this is like this totally
changes your idea of the universe
because a nucleus is a very unintuitive
non-intuitive thing it's like why is all
the mass in something that is like zero
like it basically is the realization
that matter is empty it's all empty
space and that changes everything and it
changes everything until you had that
like you had steam engines by the way
you had Telegraph wires you had all
those things but that that realization
like opened up those two realization
opened up everything like lasers ever
all these things about the modern world
of what we use
and that set it up so all I would point
out is that there's a story already that
sometimes there's these nagging things
at the edge of science that you know we
seem we Pat ourselves on the back and we
think we got everything under control
and of course that by the way that was
the origin of also that that it think
about this that was 1908 it took like
another 20 some years before people put
that together with that's the process
that's powering Stars
is the rearrangement of those nuclei not
atoms that's why Kelvin wasn't wrong he
just he was working with the wrong
assumptions right so fast forward to
today like what would this mean right
there's a couple of things like this
that sit out there in physics and I'll
point out one of them which is very
interesting we don't know what the hell
makes up 90 of the mass in the universe
so that you know the search for dark
matter right what is it we still haven't
discovered it yeah 90 of the mass of the
universe is undetectable
like what and then you know and dark
energy and again black holes are the the
window into this as well then black hole
I mean some sense black holes are way
better understood than those things as
well too so all it tells us is that we
shouldn't have hubris about the ideas
that we understand everything and when
we you know who knows what other the
next major intellectual Insight will be
about how the universe you know
functions and actually I think
Rutherford is the one who is attributed
at least that uh that quote that physics
is the only real science everything else
is stamp collecting right so uh there's
I'm sorry he's my hero but I'll slightly
disagree with that yes well no offensive
stamp collector that's very important
too
but you know that you have to have
humility about the kind of disciplines
that make progress at every stage in in
science in in science yeah that physics
did make a huge amount of progress in
the 20th century but it's possible that
other disciplines start to step in yeah
but Rutherford couldn't imagine like
mapping the human genome because we
didn't even know about DNA yeah or
computers really or computer you really
probably didn't think deeply about
computation it's like is it here's
here's a wild one what if like the next
great
Revelation to humanity about the
universe is not done by the human mind
that seems increasingly like more likely
and then you start to ask deep questions
about what is the purpose of science for
example
if
um AI system will design a nuclear
fusion reactor better than humans do but
we don't quite understand how it works
and they AI can't we know that it works
we can test it very thoroughly but we
don't know exactly what the control
mechanism is maybe what the chemistry of
the physics is uh AI can't quite explain
it they just can't it's it's
impenetrable to our Consciousness
basically trying to hold it all together
and then and then okay so now we're
living in that world where many of the
biggest discoveries are made by AI
systems yeah
uh as if we weren't going big yeah I I
say you know it's again I'll point out
like when my when when my godmother was
born like none of this was in front of
us right it's like we live in an amazing
time it's like right like my grandfather
you know plowed you know feels with a
horse
I get to work on designing Fusion
reactors yeah yeah
pretty amazing time but still there's
humans so we'll see we'll see we'll see
if that's around 100 years maybe it'll
be yeah I think we're pretty resilient
actually yeah no that's that's one
lesson from life is it uh finds a way